I don't know if you saw but the internet
really wants you to play
Marvel's Moon Knight have you heard this
I I guess I have heard this I don't
understand what a Moon Knight is sign me
up yeah okay no it's so funny when you
ask people cuz they're like yeah but
like what do I do
like it's kind of crazy I feel like I
every single time I mean I'm not very
good at social mean I find it quite
overwhelming but every single time I
kind of open Instagram it's like no no
and I'm like this is so great and thank
you but I don't know what it is like no
one's called me but yeah I would
definitely I would love to be a Marvel
superhero that would be a dream yeah
it's funny now though cuz I think fan
casting works more than ever do you
think I do
alright so tell all of all of your
viewers to go and stand outside Marvel
headquarters do you are
you're the Invisible Man yeah but you
can see me I can see you strange really
yeah I mean when you signed on for this
movie cuz universals like classic
monster movies when did you know this
was gonna be like a pretty different
take on the invisible man there's no
bandages no I mean do you know what's
really interesting I read the script and
it was called him his woman and because
the script is so original and Lee's kind
of taken this property into such a
different it's such they've done a
different road I hadn't put two and two
together that it was part of them sort
of the universal monsters universe and
so it wasn't until it was announced and
that I was playing in the I just kept on
getting these sort of messages from
people being like oh my god this is such
a huge kind of deal so it's um it's it's
grave I think Lee has written such a
fascinating story and the fact that he's
scented it you know the core of the
story is about domestic abuse and about
how much we believe women in society
when they're asking for help so it was
um it was amazing
funny yeah I'm so glad he said that
because after I watched I was like yes
it was scary and creepy and all those
things but I walked out being like
anybody has ever been like manipulated
as is like kind of a tough loss yeah I
mean I'm one I'm glad you saw that
because I do that was kind of what we
wanted with the movie you know we want
it to be fun and it is fun and it's
scary and it's creepy and entertaining
and all of that but but the core of what
the movie was talking about you know we
wanted that to kind of lost with people
and we wanted you know for anyone
watching it you know if they just go oh
someone was telling me the other day
about their boyfriend that he sort of
said something we need to keep them kind
of raising these this you know keep on
pushing this message to people that this
is not okay and yeah Lizzie and I spoke
about it a lot and we were building the
relationship for Adrian and Cecilia you
know about how she probably had tried to
leave him before and how people would
say to her oh but you live in
you have you live in such a nice house
or you have such nice clothes like I'm
sure it's fine I'm sure and he's so
lovely and like charming and you know
it's I think Lee has done a really good
job at highlighting these sort of
narcissists that we all come across in
our life your mother if she was not
crazy neither was her sister neither is
your brother neither are you
it's that house are you doing the the
season 2 of the blind man so you guys
are filming now we filming now yeah I go
back I go back to Vancouver tonight okay
so you're in two different like brains
honestly I have no idea what's happening
well what can you tease about your
character and kind of what this is
similar different from it's very very
different
so this season is called the one thing a
blonde Anna and I will get in so much
trouble if I tell you probably anything
I can tell you I did it yeah yeah it's
it's really really good
and I think that again it's where Mike
is very very clever that he wrote such a
solid season one a hill house and I
think all of us you know Victoria and I
Victoria pedretti who played my twin on
season 1 we're both back for season 2
and we're playing entirely different
characters and I think we were all a bit
anxious of with a show that had been not
successful for Netflix and how what they
were gonna do with the second one and it
is so brilliant what he's done with it
and it's a complete departure from the
hill house which I think his is right
and I think an audience's is really
gonna enjoy it yeah speaking of Victoria
did you watch new season 2 what happened
yet she's a criminal
I know I know she was telling me oh it's
crazy cause it's so fishy I watched an
episode with her back in October because
I sent her the links and so I watched a
bit of it but I hadn't more season 1 yet
and so I need to go watch back and watch
season 1 and then what season 2 but it's
crazy I mean how much people love that
show and she's she's just phenomenal I
think she's such a great great I mean
human but she's a such a great actor as
well
[Music]